camille vraiment avant tout je peux vous
aider ces dernières années vous avez
gagné le coeur des québécois et des
québécoises pour votre rôle dans la
série au secours de béatrice comment
avez vous vécu la fin de cette belle
aventure
je regarde seulement des bons souvenirs
ce que je peux pas m'empêcher pâles en
ce moment le cde risqué mais risquer
quoi cette commande la première fois que
je faisais pour la peine d'être les
visions ses 65
donc c'est un peu drôle de m'impliquer
dans sa manche un jeu très content vous
exagérez promu par le cinéma il avait
joué dans cinq films de votre frère
denis arcand oui au trou au tout début
à l'origine c'est parce que je faisais
déjà du terrain j'ai commencé les points
de vue sonore la roulotte de paul ii
selon l'année de l'exposition
universelle de tétouan et donc ça se
savait dans la maison chez nous qu mon
frère denis quand les été mis à la porte
de lou anne f à la suite de son
documentaire les ouvriers textiles a dit
bon ben je vais faire les fins de
fiction dairin avait toujours de faire
des films de fiction et en parlait déjà
à table dimanche midi donc sachant qu'il
a tourné son premier film s'était
produit par jean pierre lefebvre petite
compagnie de production n'est pas ma
mère m'aime des numides anti-roux donne
lui c'est au la mort est exaspéré c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé
si je commence gentiment un peu par
hasard entre par ce biais lotz cinquième
place qui est anecdotique
je faisais déjà du même animal
de 1981 à 1986 coup sur coup les plouffe
le crime david plouffe le déclin de
l'empiré américain dianne ekwalla tient
non le paris dakar
comment vous voyez cette grande période
là pour vous chems une succession de
petites choses séparent il n'ya pas
d'illumination le second rang la suite
le crime c'est la suite du feng shui
dans les cages de sortir 10 a péri le
déclin d'un cerveau aussi parce que je
connaissais mon frère puis j'avais
auditionné pour un autre le déclin et
puis mais finalement ils m'ont dit les
légumes pour le rôle d'un cadre unique
que je joue un peu inquiète un peu loin
de mon caractère naturel millions mais
vous deviez jouer quel personnage le
rôle pour faire d'histoires que joue
pierre curzi
mais non non je devais pas jouer ça
c'est moi qui voulaient additionner pour
ce rôle
puis j'avais mangé l'édition but d'être
prêtre très branché jamais très bon en
option pour beaucoup de mes camarades
mais c'est tellement content est étrange
des éditions que sous la personne et pas
très bons en addition ça veut rien dire
sur leur disposition à ce type mais dont
finalement mon frère des signes donnés
ces eaux là que j'ai fait mon meilleur
de ma compétence
tout ce que vous touchez se transforme
en or une nomination aux césar pour le
fils de jean est incapable de tenir
talent de cette réunion mathieu le fils
du chah tu vois a pris pour le
démantèlement si jamais il s'est
inquiété pour ce faire mais c'est une
misère au plus tôt mieux c'est un guy
des prix pour passemar thème entre
autres comment voyez-vous le potentiel
d'un projet d'un film d'auteur ton
jugement sur le scénario tôt c'est la
première journée pour faire simple on
s'habitue à ce jour tu lises beaucoup
dans la vie je pense
photo lecteur avait faut lire des romans
faut voir des séries télévisées il
faudra définir il faudra contact avec
sept partants mois de lille françois
truffaut à formuler c'est très justement
une entrevue
quand on lui avait demandé fait
différent d'un comédien acteur puis
truffaut avait dit mais oui c'est très
clair un comédien il prend des
engagements pire sa vie à côté deux ans
puis prend des engagements des
différents os il s'agit d'un acte ne
fait pas cette différence la fin de sa
vie et son travail puisse lier deux sont
liés sont pas séparés c'est ça la
différence à prendre acteurs une comédie
moi je suis plutôt un acteur et comédien
votre grand projet 2018-2019 c'est
l'adaptation du roman de laurent gaudé
écouter nos défaites
alors pourquoi avoir accepté d'embarquer
dans ce projet ça ressemble un peu à
l'oeuvre de joseph conrad au coeur des
ténèbres dont coppola fait le film
apocalypse now
[Musique]
soldat qui part à la recherche d'un
homme et je dois savoir d'abord dans
quel état mental et cette personne le
trouver dans quel état mental et il est
est ce que je dois le laisser en vie ce
jeu les mines et l'éliminer donc ça
c'est le fil conducteur du spectacle
c'est ce rapport entier deux personnes
là un peu comme le chat et la souris tu
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec lui et
il se contactent par skype ont sauté et
l'autre sont enfuis tout le temps dans
sa c4 jean gabriel arcand bien hâte de
vous revoir votre septembre et sauter
entre posture avec l'asie merci merci